This ellipse would be centered at negative 1 comma 3. It'll have an a value of
1 and it would have a b value of 5. Nice work if you got these 3 correct. We
can find this center by looking at the x squared term and the y squared term.
The x is a plus 1 x to it so that means the x coordinate of the center will be
negative 1 and the value y has a negative 3 or subtraction of 3 next to it. So,
this means that the y coordinate of the center is positive 3. Always keep in
mind that the values of h and k for our center are the opposite of these two
signs. This will always be true for circles and ellipses. So, now we need to
find the values of a and b. So, what we should do is take our equation and
divide through by 100. That will set our equation equal to 1. So, here's my
original equation and now we're going to divide each term by 100. A 100 divided
by a 100 equals 1, so this will simplify. An then we have 4 divided by a 100.
Well 4 divided by 4 equals 1. An 4 divided it into 100, equals 25. So, we'll
have 1 in our numerator, with the y minus 3 squared divided by 25 and the
denominator. I don't write the 1 here because it's just multiplication, 1 times
any expression is itself. And then finally, on the right hand side, we'll just
have 1. Now we want this equation to look like this one. But notice I don't
have an a squared term, I don't exactly have a fraction here but really I do.
Remember we can divide any expression by 1, dividing by 1 will give us this
same exact expression. So, now I can rewrite these denominators with 1 squared
equally 1 and 5 squared equaling 25. This is how we get the values away and b,
and thinking back to our center. The value of h really needs to be negative 1
in order for the equation to have positive 1. And the value of k would need to
be 3 since we'll have 3 here. So, we can see that our center is at negative 1,
3. Then we move 1 unit left and right to get 2 points on our ellipse. And we
move 5 units up and down to get two more points on the ellipse. Highlighting
these points, we can see that these two are 5 units above and below our center,
and that this point is 1 unit to the right of our center. Now desmos isn't
showing this point, but that's just because it only shows us certain points of
interest. Now, there a reason why it's only showing us these points of
interest. And when you learn more about ellipses, you'll discover why these
points are so important. For this one, it happens to be a y intercept. And, in
fact, desmos will also tell us the x intercepts. These other two points are
really important and perhaps you can do some research to figure out why.